>>We're at the age of accountability
in schools with No Child Left Behind.
And- and schools, you know,
schools have, you know,
have goals to meet
with their testing.
But I really feel that students,
unless they feel a sense
of connectedness to school
and unless they, you know,
if they don't feel a sense of
belonging, they're not gonna achieve
at the academic level that
you want them to achieve.
You know, there are a lot of
things out there right now
in school reform quick--
what I call a quick fix,
you know, for test scores.
And those things are things that
I don't feel are long-lasting
or in the best interest
of- of the school.
I think that you have to lay the
foundation and build the sense
of community within the school
and put the systems in place
of how you do business
and how you operate.
And once that foundation is
laid, the test scores will come.
But that cultural piece
has to be there.
You know, you- you can't have one
I don't believe, without the other.
One of the things that I
like to do as principal is,
I like to have conversations
with teachers about ideas
and say "Now could you go and
share this with other teachers
in your department or could
you share it with your team?"
Because I think a lot of times
principals get more resistance
from teachers if feel like that
it's coming from the top down.
I think you know, you-- I think you
get a much greater sense of buy-in
when teachers are taking
ideas to other teachers.
And- and so I think
your job as principal,
needs to be to support teacher
leaders and teachers wanting to-
to develop creative and innovative
things within your school.
And so I think that
is a key component.
I also think that-- because you
know, you've got to get buy-in
from everybody before you
do something like this.
I think my leadership style is one
where I've always been a
person that's welcomed debate.
I've always been one that I
do not feel that, you know,
I have to be the center of
the universe as principal.
I enjoy other people
stepping up and taking- taking
on the responsibilities and jobs
that need to be performed in schools
because I think true greatness
comes when everybody is involved,
when it's a- when it's
a collaborative effort.
And you know, everybody feels
that they're a partner
in- in the great work.
And not only staff
but students as well
and parents and community members.
And so I think when you get
all of those pieces together,
you have the ingredients, you have
the recipe for- for great things.
And that's- that's where we're at.
You know, we're very
early on in our work.
This is the-- in fact, this is just
year two of a- of a new school.
But the- the ingredients, the
recipes that need to be there,
the interaction the way that
business is done within the school,
the way that people
can speak up and debate
and share issues and
talk about things.
Those things are vital
to continual growth.
We became an all boys'
school this year as well.
And so in doing that and- and for us,
the boys had received the majority
of the referrals over girls.
So we doubled our boys' population
when we be- when we became all boys.
And we reduced our referrals in half.
We reduced our placements of
in-school suspensions in half.
Reduced suspensions overall,
out of school suspensions.
And- and we have increased our
attendance, our pupil attendance,
every single people month as
compared to the previous year.
We're going on 12 months now.
So created an environment I think,
of less problems in the classroom
and in the school in terms
of behavior and a sense
of students wanting to be at school.
We also do surveys as a district,
comprehensive school surveys.
And before Care For Kids, about
56, 57 percent of the students felt
like their teachers care about
them, a little over half.
When we surveyed our boys last year,
that number turned to 85 percent.
And so we saw a huge
increase in terms
of how the boys saw their teachers
and how they looked upon school
as a whole and they
wanted to be here more.
>>For more information on What Works
in Public Education
go to edutopia.org